- In conclusion, everybody
should live by themselves
because you don't need
anybody else to make
yourself happy.
(upbeat music)
Hey everyone, my name is Matt Bellassai
and this is Whine About
It a weekly video series
where I get drunk at my desk
and complain about stuff.
On this week's episode The
Worst Types of Roommates.
Let's drink.
(upbeat music)
Mmm, that's not too bad.
Okay, all right, first of
all there's always that one
roomate who never takes out the garbage.
You think this is some kind of game?
You think this is some kind of gabage game
where if you pile your
tower of shame tall enough
a little garbage fairy
will come and take all your
garbage away, little
garbage fairy will just come
and gobble up your garbage?
Guess what, the garbage
fairy it's me, it's me
who's the garbage fairy.
I take out all the (bleep)
garbage all the time,
and that's why I use your
toothbrush to scrub the toilet
and I get in there deep.
Then, there's that roommate
she's always in there
with her boyfriend and
they're just bumping uglies
way too loud all the time.
Congrats on all the sex your
having, I'm so happy for you
but if I have to hear
you shouting the lyrics
to Ave Maria while you're
in there stirring your
potato salad while I'm trying
to watch The Real Housewives
I'm gonna spit in your box of
Special K with Red Berries,
again, I'm gonna spit right in it.
You know that sound that
it makes when you stir up
a cold potato salad?
That's the sound it makes, like
two wet slugs just rammin'.
Then, there's the one
roommate who thinks it's okay
to eat my food right out of
the fridge, like I'm not even
gonna notice.
If you think for a second
that I don't count every stick
of the sweet potato fries
that are in the fridge
you're out of your (bleep) damn mind.
Food is like my children.
Food is like my babies.
You think it's okay to
just come into my fridge
and eat my babies, eat
up all my little babies?
Every time someone eats my
food I reserve the right
to punch 'em right in the kidney,
It's in the Constitution, look it up.
That's what our Founding Fathers said.
They didn't even have two kidneys then,
all of them only had one.
Benjamin Franklin, one kidney.
That's why it was so important to them.
Then, there's that one
roomate who just never
does the dishes.
They just let 'em pile up
in a whole wet, crusty mess.
"Oh, I forgot," that's what they say.
"Oh, I just forgot to do the dishes."
Oh, you just forgot for
three months straight
while that family of squirrels
moved in under that pot
that couldn't scrub for 20 seconds.
Maybe I'll just forget not to
tell everbody about that thing
I saw you doing in the bathroom
with the bottle of mustard.
What if I just didn't forget
that, is that what you want?
Is that what you want?
You want me to just not
forget that and tell everybody
about the bottle of mustard?
Also, why are the so
many (bleep) damn pubes
on your bar of soap?
What are you doing down there?
What are you doing to yourself?
Show some respect.
I don't even know how you
use that soap to get clean.
That looks like an angry hedgehog.
It's just in there growling back at me,
it's looking me right in the face
with its two furry little eyes,
furrowing it's pubey brow.
Also, roommates who terrorize
my Netflix suggestions
'cause they go in there and
they watch all their shitty
dumb shows.
It's all garbage is what they watch.
And, I'm getting suggestions
for some crime watching
goat detective mystery all
because you watched 30 seconds
of some shit on my Netflix account.
I don't want that, I don't want
that on my Netflix account.
Also, any roommate who
deletes a single second
off of my DVR.
My DVR is like a sandwich.
I picked out all the
meats, and all cheeses,
and all the breads and
it's like you came in here
you just took a big, old pee right on it.
You peed on my sandwich, my DVR sandwich.
That's why everyone
should live by themselves,
no roommates.
Okay, okay, okay?
All right everybody, thank
you for watching this week.
As always, you can find
our videos every week
on WhineAboutIt.tumblr.com,
on my Facebook page
which is Facebook.com/BuzzFeedMatt.
That's it, that's everything.
(upbeat music)
Everyone's always like,
"Matt, what do you do at work
"when you're done?"
Nothing.